[SPEAKER_02]: All right, so you've just got to roll six.
[SPEAKER_00]: Roll six side and see what boat you're in.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's not a six.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's a square one.
[SPEAKER_00]: One.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh.
[SPEAKER_00]: All of you are in the second boat.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_03]: Second Wealsun at around 4.30 p.m.
[SPEAKER_03]: The Marine Unit leaves the Cossaire and begins heading towards the southern beacon.
[SPEAKER_03]: The box of the southern beacon.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, so...
[SPEAKER_03]: Lower it in and you guys begin rowing up to there.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yep, I'm on an oar.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'll tear that up.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm definitely on an oar.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, so what do you guys want to do?
[SPEAKER_03]: I want to be at the head of the boat.
[SPEAKER_03]: Kind of looking at things?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'll be at the back of the boat where my sergeant is.
[SPEAKER_03]: The ship continues around this way, and it takes you guys about 20 minutes to reach the shore from where you're at.
[SPEAKER_03]: The sea and the waves are not bad in this part.
[SPEAKER_03]: It's a very clear day.
[SPEAKER_03]: And you begin to approach the docks.
[SPEAKER_02]: And we can't see what's going on because we're bats to it, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: Or what's going on?
[SPEAKER_01]: You can look around.
[SPEAKER_01]: We're not actively like... Am I noticing anything that I wouldn't notice being around here before?
[SPEAKER_01]: What do you want to do?
[SPEAKER_03]: So, you have several powers as a ranger.
[SPEAKER_03]: If you want to, you can just keep your eyes out and do a survival roll to see if you see anything strange.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: Just do that.
[SPEAKER_04]: Roll a 20-sided die.
[SPEAKER_04]: Hit that little magnet.
[SPEAKER_04]: Survival.
[SPEAKER_00]: Four.
[SPEAKER_00]: You don't really notice anything.
[SPEAKER_00]: We're dead.
[SPEAKER_00]: We're all dead.
[SPEAKER_03]: Keep your eyes open.
[SPEAKER_04]: What was your survival skill?
[SPEAKER_04]: Plus six.
[SPEAKER_04]: Oh.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, you do notice something.
[SPEAKER_01]: How about sharks in the water?
[SPEAKER_01]: More than I've seen before.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Thanks.
[SPEAKER_01]: Bring out my longbow.
[SPEAKER_01]: I just bring it out not ready for battle, but for seething, and I'm going to tell them, be mindful, there's a lot of sharks out right now.
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't know if something died from feasting or...
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't know.
[SPEAKER_01]: I've never seen sharks like this around this area before, so be very mindful coming in and out of the boat.
[SPEAKER_00]: Take a look over the side and look at the water a little more closely.
[SPEAKER_00]: Don't see anything.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Just be mindful.
[SPEAKER_01]: Be careful.
[SPEAKER_04]: Sharks near Helm Island?
[SPEAKER_04]: There are never sharks near Helm Island.
[SPEAKER_01]: I know.
[SPEAKER_01]: Very interesting.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: Very interesting.
[SPEAKER_04]: So, you guys reach the docks and what's even more interesting as you approach is the sergeant says, well there are sharks but there are no men.
[SPEAKER_04]: I would expect somebody to welcome us as we come up.
[SPEAKER_04]: You reach the docks.
[SPEAKER_04]: The first ship gets there.
[SPEAKER_04]: And the first platoon gets out onto the docks, pulls up their longboat, ties it off.
[SPEAKER_04]: And the 15 men, five crosswomen, Marines, basically are standing there waiting.
[SPEAKER_04]: They assemble.
[SPEAKER_04]: And the sergeant goes, Folsom, give the signal to prepare weapons.
[SPEAKER_04]: All right, I pull out my fight and just do like a little...
[SPEAKER_04]: The guys all whip out the weapons and start loading their crossbows as the second ship runs up next to the back one, the bottom one.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's what we're on, right?
[SPEAKER_04]: Exactly.
[SPEAKER_04]: Comes up behind and the captain goes, unload!
[SPEAKER_00]: Or the sergeant goes, unload!
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: So you guys get off.
[SPEAKER_00]: Shoot, what am I armed with then?
[SPEAKER_00]: Do your survival roll.
[SPEAKER_00]: Two.
[SPEAKER_00]: Plus six.
[SPEAKER_00]: You don't notice any.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right.
[SPEAKER_00]: Let's get off this dock.
[SPEAKER_00]: Let's get off this dock onto solid land.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Lead the men, Tyrus.
[SPEAKER_02]: All right.
[SPEAKER_03]: Marines in front.
[SPEAKER_02]: Archers in back.
[SPEAKER_00]: Shield out.
[SPEAKER_00]: Where's the boat from your left?
[SPEAKER_00]: On the dock.
[SPEAKER_02]: Not our boat, but the... Yeah, both of them are right there.
[SPEAKER_02]: We're on the dock.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, and the main Cosaire is starting to go around over here.
[SPEAKER_04]: This way.
[SPEAKER_04]: They're going to be going like this.
[SPEAKER_02]: Right.
[SPEAKER_02]: Into the bag.
[SPEAKER_02]: All right, so obviously we need to signal them whether it's clear or not.
[SPEAKER_02]: And there's no signal coming from this whatsoever right now.
[SPEAKER_02]: No signal.
[SPEAKER_02]: Zero.
[SPEAKER_02]: There's a light on, but it's daytoned.
[SPEAKER_02]: So the fire is burning, but that's it.
[SPEAKER_02]: But usually there would be some sort of signaling that went along there.
[SPEAKER_04]: Well, what's really strange is...
[SPEAKER_04]: That's a guard tower, and you don't see anybody on that guard tower.
[SPEAKER_04]: And this is the dogs, and normally they would see you coming from a mile away, and they would come down there to greet you guys.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, because it's the middle of the day.
[SPEAKER_02]: All right.
[SPEAKER_02]: So let's move to the... Well, role play.
[SPEAKER_02]: Do you want to basically talk to the sergeants?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, see, let's go to the tower.
[SPEAKER_02]: Because you're not leading, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm in front.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: We should go to the tower.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'll say, do you want me to take the men of the tower first?
[SPEAKER_02]: That's what I'll say.
[SPEAKER_04]: This is strange.
[SPEAKER_04]: We should, definitely we should go to the tower.
[SPEAKER_04]: They said the barracks, but we should investigate.
[SPEAKER_04]: Merrick, do you see anything strange on the beach or anywhere?
[SPEAKER_01]: General sir, survival or?
[SPEAKER_01]: What are you going to look for?
[SPEAKER_01]: Tracks?
[SPEAKER_01]: On the dirt or anything like that, or in the sand?
[SPEAKER_01]: Can you scout around?
[SPEAKER_01]: Absolutely.
[SPEAKER_03]: All right, everyone stay alert.
[SPEAKER_03]: Merrick, see what you can find.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm keeping my eyes on him with my crossbow.
[SPEAKER_03]: And the rest of the men look at the ridge up the quays, basically.
[SPEAKER_02]: Form up the ranks and start moving towards the...
[SPEAKER_02]: Tower.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, so you're gonna head towards the Quays and there's like stairs that go up to the top part of the ridge, but you're on the beach right now.
[SPEAKER_04]: The sergeant wants you to stay on the beach until Merrick finishes his investigation.
[SPEAKER_04]: So you look around for 10 minutes.
[SPEAKER_04]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Roll.
[SPEAKER_00]: Twenty?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Six.
[SPEAKER_00]: Plus six?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Is that your turkey die?
[SPEAKER_00]: You find a footprint in the sand actually heading toward the quay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Obviously it's been since the last tide because anything that leads up to it is gone.
[SPEAKER_04]: This is a bare print and
[SPEAKER_04]: It seemed like the foot was webbed.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I'm a little shaken up by this.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, I'm gonna report back.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm gonna... You go back up to the sergeant?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, and tell him what I saw.
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't want to alert and scare all the other men, but I'm gonna tell...
[SPEAKER_01]: So you whisper.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: I say I'm unsettled because it appears to be a footprint I haven't seen in a long time on these beaches.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm kind of just taken aback because I thought what I think it is went extinct a long time ago or it was taken out.
[SPEAKER_01]: So this is very unsettling and very unnerving.
[SPEAKER_01]: What do you mean?
[SPEAKER_01]: Spit it out.
[SPEAKER_01]: It appears that, uh, I'm thinking the thrillers have me too that it's the shoglin, shark people.
[SPEAKER_04]: That's impossible.
[SPEAKER_04]: They haven't come to Helms Island in centuries.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, but when we pulled up, I noticed a lot of sharks in the water as well.
[SPEAKER_01]: So something's very wrong here.
[SPEAKER_01]: Something I haven't seen in a long, long time.
[SPEAKER_04]: We have magical protections on this island, as far as I know.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, there are greater magics in the world.
[SPEAKER_01]: You never know.
[SPEAKER_01]: We're not privy to this, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: Because we're... Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm definitely not because I'm way away from it.
[SPEAKER_03]: Well, we're not fighting them in the ocean.
[SPEAKER_03]: We'll go up the Quays.
[SPEAKER_03]: Tyrus, take us up the Quays.
[SPEAKER_02]: Alright.
[SPEAKER_02]: We're gonna get up these stairs and then start to form a rank and I'll be in the front, shield out, heading towards the
[SPEAKER_02]: This here, the tower.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, so you guys assemble at the top of the quays, at the top of the stair.
[SPEAKER_03]: You form the ranks, and do you want it 20 men wide, 10 men wide?
[SPEAKER_03]: Do you want the crossbowmen behind, I take it?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes, absolutely.
[SPEAKER_02]: Crossbowmen behind, but make it like 10 wide.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: 10 wide.
[SPEAKER_02]: I want the rows deep.
[SPEAKER_03]: So, two deep with the guys with the shields marching forward and the crossbow men behind.
[SPEAKER_03]: All right.
[SPEAKER_03]: And you are in the front one.
[SPEAKER_03]: Right.
[SPEAKER_03]: You guys begin marching forward.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: Do you go crossbow?
[SPEAKER_03]: I do not.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: You just have raked it up.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's playing his fight.
[SPEAKER_01]: Can I take up the rear and continue to look around?
[SPEAKER_01]: Absolutely.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: So we're off the dock now, I take it.
[SPEAKER_04]: We're all going up to the... Yeah, you're off the dock and you're marching towards the barracks and the tower, correct?
[SPEAKER_01]: Mm-hmm.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: I assume all of you are like looking around trying to figure stuff out.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_02]: Mostly windows, openings, sides of the buildings.
[SPEAKER_04]: All of you roll perception.
[SPEAKER_00]: 15, 6, plus 6, plus 2, 10.
[SPEAKER_00]: 18.
[SPEAKER_00]: 18?
[SPEAKER_00]: 17.
[SPEAKER_00]: I got 6, so plus 6, 12.
[SPEAKER_00]: 12?
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: I got a 17.
[SPEAKER_04]: Gouge.
[SPEAKER_04]: Aristotle.
[SPEAKER_04]: You see somebody staring out of one of the windows of
[SPEAKER_04]: The tower as you approach.
[SPEAKER_04]: But as soon as you look up, they dart back.
[SPEAKER_04]: Tyrus, you see the same thing from one of the buildings at the barracks.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: A very strange feeling comes over you because these people seem to be very shy for some reason.
[SPEAKER_04]: However, you know they're there.
[SPEAKER_04]: The rest of the men kind of feel this as well.
[SPEAKER_04]: Some people seeing them
[SPEAKER_02]: Looking at you.
[SPEAKER_02]: Was it human form or could I tell?
[SPEAKER_03]: I don't know if you can really tell that.
[SPEAKER_03]: What you can tell is it moved like human.
[SPEAKER_03]: Like somebody was looking and their face, they move out of the way.
[SPEAKER_00]: So I turn back to look at Merrick, try to get his attention as I'm looking.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: I just shout.
[SPEAKER_02]: Someone's in the barracks.
[SPEAKER_03]: You shout, someone's in the barracks?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: A bolt streaks out and hits your shield, like right when you say that.
[SPEAKER_03]: Someone shoots from one of the arrow slits there.
[SPEAKER_03]: In the tower, though.
[SPEAKER_03]: In the tower.
[SPEAKER_03]: From the tower down upon you.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: You're probably around, I would say, 100 feet from the tower right now.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay?
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: That's why I rolled an advantage, because you didn't see who the guy was.
[SPEAKER_03]: All of a sudden, on top of the tower, guys start, creatures, humans, whatever they are, humanoids, start coming out of the doorways on the defensive levels to take up firing positions upon you.
[SPEAKER_04]: We're going to roll initiative in a second.
[SPEAKER_04]: Bye.
[SPEAKER_04]: Hang on.